it's an update to a story we first
Brought You in September Helping Seniors
get access to food and after our story
aired one local non-profit reached out
to help in hopes of Bridging the Gap
when it comes to seniors and food
insecurity
residents at the Royal mobile home park
in the Northeast Valley can now enjoy a
Thanksgiving meal this holiday season
now kokomora is the founder of a local
non-profit called the Center for Women
and families abroad she says her
non-profit has limited resources but
helps in any way she can this is from my
personal experience I was a single
mother and we I went through some
struggles in the past and I do
understand
how important to help others so I
decided to do this with 80 bags of food
filled with canned goods and boxed meals
Community manager Virginia buzzart says
this will help feed 50 to 60 struggling
families it's really hard I have one
tenant that he only gets like 900 a
month
and it's very hard for him and I try to
help as much as I can but I can only do
so much Mae Simpson first reached out to
us for help back in September she says
she is overwhelmed with the quick
response and generosity from those
willing to help when I came in and saw
how much food there was I was actually
blown away it was tremendous you know
suddenly I did not expect
and as a way to give back Channel 8
staff did help bag and distribute the
food as well and Kimura says she hopes
to help others in the community who need
help accessing food